hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about you know
fresh liquidity coming into the market
as opposed to resting liquidity which is
orders that are sitting in the order
book right and if you're looking at a
dome or depth of Market you know you're
looking at the resting liquidity but
what I want to focus on today is the
fresh liquidity the liquidity that is
constantly coming in and um by by fresh
liquidity I'm going to be focusing in on
the big bids or big offers and in this
video I'll be talking about the big bids
coming in all right so before I get
started you know before I jump in if you
enjoy learning from my videos be sure to
uh subscribe to the channel and click
the notification Bell so you know when I
post a new video you'll be notified of
it so you won't miss it and if you find
today's video helpful hit the like
button and you know leave a comment
below sharing your biggest takeaway you
know I love hearing your feedback all
right so liquidity okay and fresh
liquidity what fresh liquidity is is it
refers to new buy and sell orders that
are coming in on the bid or the offer
right people that provide liquidity to
the market you know people that buy at
the market or sell at the market are
removing liquidity but when someone
comes in and bids You Know Places a bid
or places an offer they are providing
liquidity okay and you know this influx
of fresh orders right you know helps
replenish and sustain the overall
liquidity in the market and you know the
reason why fresh liquidity as opposed to
to resting liquidity um is important is
because it improves um you know I say uh
trading opportunity but you know when
there's lack of liquidity you know
Market's going to move around pretty
quick right because the market is always
searching for liquidity all right so
today in the snps um there's there's a
good example of fresh liquidity that
failed I'm going to talk about I'll show
you an example of fresh liquidity that
held and really when you're you're
dealing with fresh liquidity coming into
the market you want to notice is it
holding or is it failing okay that
that's the key because if it's holding
right if fresh liquidity comes in on the
bid and it holds you're going to expect
the market to go up if fresh liquidity
comes on the bid meaning a strong Bid
And it fails you're going to be looking
for the market to go down and you know
is one more important than the other you
know one that holds and one that fails
well when it holds it could often
indicate a reversal if it fails it could
just be um
you know a sign that the market has some
strength directional strength and you
know it's probably going to continue
going down right if it's a fresh
liquidity on the bid which today there
was um that you know there's strong
selling right it's just overrunning
whatever buying took place in the market
on the passive bids okay so you know
just really quick you know I made a
video the other day talking about the
difference between um passive buyers and
passive Sellers and aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers right anything
that is on the bid and below is passive
buying anything that's on the offer and
above is passive selling aggressive
sellers sell to passive buyers
aggressive buyers buy from passive
Sellers and on the footprint right if it
trades on the bid side that was a
passive seller that
bought from an aggressive seller okay
again you know there's always if you
have an aggressive seller he's selling
to a passive buyer if you have an
aggressive buyer he's buying from a
passive seller and today this morning in
the snps there was some big fresh
liquidity that came into the market here
it came in here at 5205 came in again at
5203 and just recently it came in at 52
um was it
5200 couple times here where are we uh
here okay so Market dropping
okay let's just uh for reference let's
take a look here at the the bar chart
okay and the time that I'm referring to
is um you know right in here between
basically 9 and 9:30 okay 5205
5203 and again you know just put it in
reference from overnight you know
overnight we're trading up at uh you
know go back here right 5245 52 not 50
but you know above 45 so this is uh you
know Market had sold off 45 points okay
and actually got down to uh 5194 and A4
rallied back up to to uh 18 and 3/4 and
then it starts coming back down then you
see big bids coming in here okay and
they failed now you see the market is
continuing to sell off all right so
let's take a look here at this fresh
liquidity now how do you define fresh
liquidity right I I earlier I talked
about fresh liquidity I talked about
resting liquidity resting liquidity is
orders that is sitting in the book so
for example right if the market comes
down you know there's probably bids down
here you know when we're trading 5245
you know bids in there at 10 at 7 you
know 6 5 that is resting liquidity but
when the market trades through those
prices right clears out that liquidity
so all this resting liquidity that was
here from you know 13 11 10 9 8 that's
all cleared out Market bounces back and
then you see fresh strong bids coming in
okay so let's take a look at the
footprint okay so just uh here try and
fit it on my screen okay it's 9 o' right
we trade well you know earlier right
Cash open we're trading below 5200 right
we're trading we rally up to
50 you know what is at you know 18 and
3/4 then you start coming back down 9 o'
right we got this big bar where we trade
basically from 14 down to you know four
and a quarter going sideways a little
bit right remember we just traded 05
right at this bar at 9:00 right you just
trade 05 at the bar at
9:03 904
905 but at this point here right you see
the market starts going
up there's a big bid that comes in and
and you can see it in here right it's
holding for basically 2 minutes right
you see finally here it fails you can
see the volume
2,226 so that's basically about 3,000
here on the bid that is fresh liquidity
how do I Define it as fresh liquidity
because it's just in an area that we
were just trading it wasn't sitting in
the order book right if this 3,000
contracts that traded over these three
minutes was in the order book you would
see it here right you wouldn't trade
through it like we did here you see only
185 traded through it but then when it
came in here right it's holding right
the bar it shot up next bar came down
trade 600 went back up right this bar
opened up went higher cuz you know
people realize there's a big bid in here
at ' 05 this big bid is trying to
support the
market okay then it starts coming back
down it's getting hit right you see it
trades out right it's got big negative
Delta minus 2297 but it it trades out
and then the Market's now looking for
more liquidity how do I know because I
see there's lack of liquidity trading
here on the volumes right on the offer
side is one
003 even on the bid side 57 67 43 88
that's very thin volume and oft times
when you get through a big volume
level the market runs a bit fast because
you know sometimes there's people that
are you know trying to scalp this big
bid here by scalping I mean you know
they're going to jump in front at at 2
and a quarter maybe try to sell it or
sorry at five and a quarter maybe try to
sell it at you know at six and a quarter
or even six and or five and 3/4 you know
just trying to scalp a few ticks out of
it and they're going to place a stop
right
here we break there Market drops down
immediately from 05 down to 02 that's a
threo drop not three ticks three points
okay and then you know goes down to 02
then another big bid comes in here at 03
you see the 1500 this is also liquidity
it it's not holding the market it just
trades through it really quick so I got
you know the 2,000 here plus the 620
plus the 450 so you know you're looking
at close to 3,000 here another 15500 is
coming in here two points below okay
it's not holding the market so you know
this Market has some strong directional
trading taking place because normally
right on a sort of on a normal day
normal you know a market that's rotating
around um you know big bids or big
offers come in and it's going to act as
support or resistance but we just blow
through the first level second level
comes in we blow through that
immediately right this happened very
early in the bar right this it's not
just rotating around like it did here
for three minutes this big bid came in
someone whacked
it right and the market even in this bar
drops from 03 down to 98 and a qu next
bar gets down to 97 and 3/4 next bar
gets down to 97 and a qu then you start
rotating around between you know 5200
and and back up to 03 and what do you
see right again you're trading in that
area for 1 2 3 four five six bars
seven look at this volume 597 1,400
fresh liquidity is still coming in here
so there's still a strong buyer now
again we don't know the only person that
knows why this why there's some strong
bids coming in here you know from 05 03
o is the person trading it okay and
remember you know yesterday we did have
a nice big
rally okay you know from basically from
85 all the way up to 55 overnight
basically going sideways around 45 this
morning we're selling off so maybe the
person that's buying here they could be
covering from yesterday we don't know
but what we do know is we have strong
bids that's not acting as support as we
would normally expect it so if we know
we have strong bids in the market that's
not acting as support what do we infer
from that well we infer that we're
probably in a flow driven Market that
anytime there's big size you know it's
probably going to fail it's not going to
um necessarily react and um look for a
big bounce off the mark off that off
that level and you see we did trade back
up to
05 and then now you know right now we're
trading where where are we 80 seven so
we're in a flow driven market and when
you're in a flow driven
Market you got to understand that you
can't necessarily trade with a tight
stop because you're going to get bounces
right and again you know if you are
shorting it in here seeing after this
failure this failure maybe getting short
you know around 5200 you know if you got
a two-point stop you know you got to
give it more leeway right you can see it
even trades all the way back up to 06
before it breaks I mean so again if
you're shorting at 5200 right now we're
trading you know in the mid 80s okay
now take what I just talked about okay
and we're going to go back um a couple
days to I think it was Wednesday right
when CPI came out today's Friday um so
that was on the
10th and something kind of similar but
it was a case where it held now if you
remember right
on earlier in the week right CPI came
out big drop down okay went back up
started selling off then we we came back
down around this 85 area bounced back up
to to 14 sort of the way it's looking
today you know we're coming back down to
85 we'll see if we bounce back up to 14
or not
but uh let's take a look at that
move where are we here
on 12 so if I remember
correctly yeah 1211 okay
so don't worry about these lines these
are from today but you can see this
Market this was on Wednesday now this is
a case where the fresh liquidity is
holding okay and it did run into some
resting liquidity but fresh liquidity is
also coming in so we Dro down from
basically 52 um you know 14 we get all
the way down to
85 right again 85 a nice
number you know nice whole
number trade 18
contracts first
time second time we trade you know 417
third time we trade 1,69 now this at 85
okay to me is resting liquidity because
it's there you know as the market is
coming down but what is very important
to
notice this 8807 this is big size okay
807 coming in here at 85 and a quarter
and what's important about it is because
we just traded
85 trade 85 and a quarter here and again
here and actually we again we trade down
to 85 but this
807 this is a new order coming in so you
have the resting liquidity at 85 and
just off of that you have a strong bid
coming in this
807 okay and again you know we trade
through it get down to 85 one tick
through it again it's not the end of the
world that it trades one tick through it
but more importantly you have a strong
bid coming in ahead of wrestling
liquidity and it's holding how do I know
it's holding is because it's not getting
through it and the market is starting to
trade above it right if it starts
failing I would look at it the same way
I looked at today's action
right then it starts rallying right you
get nice um you know positive Delta on
this bar nice buying and balances you
got like six here Market starts going up
right as and as it's going up what do
you see on this move
up this bar here nice big green candle
Market's looking for more liquidity how
do I know is because people are tripping
over themselves trying to buy you can
see all these buying and balances very
thin volume here 2 2 1 zero bunch of
zeros and then boom somebody sits here
on the bid at 98 for 2,300 contracts so
this buyer here at 98 probably started
down here around 95 just swept the
market all the way up to 98 sat on the
bid to support the market okay and what
does it do does it hold it holds Market
goes higher from 98 and a quarter gets
all the way up to O in a quarter comes
back down trades through it trades three
contracts through it again not the end
of the world it trades three contracts
through it goes back up similar strong
bids coming in here at 5 and 3/4
1,400 Market's still running get some
more strong bids up here th000
1999 you know that's 3,000 contracts
right there you know then just sort of
goes sideways then you still got a
strong bid coming up here on this red
candle a thousand right this is like
fomo right if if you trying to picture
what fomo looks like in the order flow
this is what it looks like and it was
all key you know for the you know the
the trader that's really more advanc
because to be honest it's more of an
advanced concept watching the actual
volumes in here and understanding this
is fresh liquidity that came in right
here you you key in on this but maybe
you're not convinced yet right maybe you
want to see some more activity you know
by the time this bar comes in with you
know the strong Delta the strong buying
imbalances you should be sort of ready
to take advantage of it right and again
it's a move from basically 90 91 92 all
the way up to you know not saying that
you'd hold it all the way up to here but
you know it's it's a nice move you know
an easy uh 10 points right and then you
get that bar these are those bars that
you're like ah yes thank you God um you
know where it just jumps from 92 and a
half all the way up to double
O so you know hope you can start to
understand the importance of not just
resting liquidity right people that
trade on a book map on on a heat map
watching the Dome they're all watching
resting liquidity but really you know if
you could focus on Fresh liquidity
coming into the market I think it's just
as important as resting liquidity okay
because you know that continuous flow of
fresh liquidity I mean there's always
fresh liquidity coming in but when I'm
referring to Fresh liquidity I'm talking
about big size coming into the market um
you know it it creates new trading
opportunities for you right as you know
and again new buy and sell orders are
constantly being placed in the market
right and you know when you see that
fresh liquidity for size come in pay
attention to it watch how the market is
reacting to it all right so again you
know I hope you enjoyed this video be
sure to subscribe to the channel if you
haven't you know I'm very close to uh
hitting some Milestones on subscribers
so you know thanks and I'll catch you
guys on the next video bye-bye